pitch the film version of your game I
think mine would be the hangover but
with crash bandicoot that would be
increasing that is just like in Vegas
like this is versus the GameSpot show
that pits your favorite games consoles
franchises and hot burn issues against
each other this week it's the Battle of
the ps1 platforming trilogies as we pit
spyro against crash finding the Spyro is
oscar Deus who looked up to the little
purple dragon like the father figure he
never had and arguing the case for crash
is Wil Potter who is a few wumpa fruit
short of an orchard each you're going to
argue the corn for their game over the
course of three randomly picked topics
with the overall winner being decided by
you the wonderful viewer last week's
fight between Uncharted and tomb raider
saw oscar notch up another win with 65%
of the vote for is and charted arguments
but can he make it two in a row this
week to be on this episode we're going
to be throwing up a clickable poll right
here on YouTube
vote for who you think has argued a case
better by clicking on the little I in
the top right corner at any point during
the video and casting your vote or if
you're watching this over on GameSpot
come let us know who you think is when
the debate in the comments section below
right and I found me let's get into it
[Music]
they'll usually start of these episodes
we smack-talk each other and say how
we're going to knock each other out or
test each other's chin but yeah you're
just a nice guy and I quite like crash
bandicoot as well you know I'm not gonna
smack talk to you today thanks but it
sure you want to do this I mean you are
bringing your baby dragon game up
against Crash Bandicoot baby dragon
babies shut up you're a baby into this
alright let's do this first topic level
design to me it's pretty obvious that
even though I think some of crashes
levels are some of some of crashes
levels are very very good alright I
think Spyro has a more diverse range of
levels if you look at the kinds of
locales that you go to you go from ice
rinks to underwater beaches to a super
secret spy mission in a fireworks
factory and it's that variety that I
think makes Spyro so good and it's not
only a variety in terms of the actual
levels and the level design and you know
some of them employee verticality really
well and some of them are a lot more
flat everything changes from level to
level both in terms of the design and in
terms of the art style I don't know is
is that it's that variety that I think
keeps things so interesting in the Spyro
series you say that but crash has
variety - yeah Steve you've got
underwater
you've got mad castles you've got future
space levels but the thing I like about
crash is it's a bit more focused it's
more linear you are going from A to B
you're not wandering around with your
dragon the flying maze collecting gems
or whatever it is you're doing well you
are collecting crash is more focused so
you are getting a better more efficient
gameplay experience and what that means
for the levels is that I think they can
create a more interesting game for you
by funding funneling you down these
paths with obstacles with spike traps
and lava pits and crazy enemies and
secret parts that you don't always find
the first time through and I think
they're so expertly crafted that when
you get to the end of the level you want
to go back and try it again
so like what I miss like you want to
explore every inch a lot of what you
just said there I agree with what you're
saying but I think it's actually a
disadvantage for very much because I
prefer the openness of Spyros worlds
especially if you look at the way games
have evolved to this very day like games
are generally a lot more open now and
Spyro was sort of one of the first games
really to properly do that in 3d you can
go to any part of the level and it will
reward you for exploring and for trying
something different and even when you go
back like you said about replaying them
I think that's more fun because they're
more open it's more diverse even within
their levels I think crash because they
are more linear once you've done it once
you've sort of done it every time do I
mean there's not a huge amount of
diversity when you go back and do it
again I think where crash mixes it up is
you are getting from A to B and
collecting the crystal but you're not
always doing that just as crash you are
riding a motorbike you are flying an
aeroplane you're riding a polar bear
I don't think spy.road has that much
diversity in form in the way that you
are now because Spyro can do it all
himself can he even he can fly all right
well glide and he can breathe fire and
he done and he can swim
he doesn't need too much or in nobody
can ride a skateboard can he ride a
tiger
probably but can you ride a tiger crash
can know a billion Potter yes I have
ridden a tiger Oh fair enough let's call
it a day and then come all right see you
later
characters which game has the best
characters Spyro obvious know obviously
crash oh yeah I mean he doesn't have all
to say there he is the master of
slapstick yes you're dying over and over
and over but it's not miserable that
Dark Souls
I love Dark Souls uh-huh but sorry
science if you fall into an ice lake do
you turn into a human icicle maybe I
don't know you don't okay and if you get
electrocuted you see crashes skeleton
and if you are blowing up his eyeballs
go off in different directions that's
what I love about crash I think he is a
funny character yeah what you're saying
is the best thing about crash
is the fact that he dies yeah but he
gets back up again
obviously great supporting cast mm-hmm
his sister Coco I could a clue the mask
who helps you along what a minute
and then yeah exactly and then the mad
villains cortex is just hilarious like
you can't take him seriously and that's
the point Mike he's he's a funny you
villain it's for its nearly as big as
yours playing truth I was gonna wear a
big animal man couldn't get the printer
working I think crash does have a really
interesting Castle Karras and I do like
the slap to slapstick element took
crashed like you said but I think you
have to you can't look past Spyro and
the fact that he's a really bloody cool
dragon who breathes fire and joy he was
actually quite a role model for me as
well when I was growing up because yeah
yeah he was because he was one of the
small he was the smallest dragon in that
community and he was constantly told
that he wasn't good enough and he was
too small and it would never make it as
a professional footballer okay it's okay
it's not okay bill but no genuinely he
is like a really really funny character
who's got a wisecrack on him almost like
the crash successor that Nathan Drake if
you will weirdly don't take my franchise
I'll do whatever write down well one
crash bandicoot's Naughty Dog but I
think the other thing about the Spyro
games is that the supporting cast of
characters was really good as well like
in Year of the Dragon you had all these
companion characters like sergeant bird
and Bentley the Yeti Sheila the the
kangaroo and agent 9 is where I can't
forget that all had their own unique
play styles and unique levels that were
again made the game so diverse and also
that I think the best character isn't
even Spyro the best character is Sparks
the dragonfly even though he doesn't say
a word almost like you assume a crash he
doesn't say a word and yet there's so
much character in him
you depend on him for the entire game or
the the entirety of all three games and
he becomes not only a friend but also a
much-needed companion and you feel so
vulnerable and so lost when he's not
there partly because if you get one more
hit you're dead ball so because he's
constant companion for you and you can't
help but feel lost without him he's a
bug yeah he's not a cool like possessed
mask that can make you invincible I mean
that's true yeah he can make you
invincible kind of where he gives you
extra lives so that counts is invincible
right okay
whereas crash it's just I mean of crash
himself year he's fine his deaths are
funny but like at the end of the day
he's a band hoon have you seen what
those things look like in real life
because they are pathetic much like you
and your arguments stop this I'll have
nothing said about bandicoot's unless
its praise praise the Bandicoot yeah I
built final topic what is it
legacy ooh the lasting impact of our
respective series well I think Spyro
personally I think Spyro has had more of
a lasting impact upon sure about the
yeah I am yeah you see yeah so screw you
okay explain you only have to look at
the biggest spyro game and really the
most recent sort of officer of the the
Spyro franchise has been Skylanders
which not only spawned a hugely
successful series in itself but actually
spawned an entire genre by itself it
toys to life was not a thing before
Skylanders came along which let's not
forget was a spyro game and without that
we wouldn't obviously have Disney
infinity or lego dimensions or even an
ebow like amiibo were clearly massively
influenced by Skylanders and by Spyro
and let's not forget that the original
three games are still there for you to
play and enjoy and soon they're going to
be joined by the reignited trilogy which
I'm absolutely buzzing for I can't wait
for it because like those three games
are some of my favorite games ever and
they were sort of the three games that
made me fall in love with gaming and so
I can't wait to play them all again so I
think it's pretty clear that aspera has
an incredibly lasting legacy both in
terms of the industry and personally on
me that's a fair argument but you are
wrong
I mean clearly crash has a much stronger
history and legacy obviously crash team
racing which rivaled Mario Kart back in
the day that game was incredible yeah
Crash Team Racing was killed in furnace
crash bash sort of like a Mario Party
masher
with all of your favorite crash
bandicoot characters like the polar bear
here's my favorite but let's not forget
Naughty Dog you've made crash bandicoot
what did they go on to make what was
another game that sent you to different
parts of the world and have you run away
from boulders I'll try it and I think
you can see like from Crash Bandicoot
all the way through Naughty Dog's
history there are its maintained
influences from those original games and
of course insane trilogy one of if not
the best-selling remaster on ps4 that
game sold like hotcakes and for good
reason because it's really good it takes
everything you love from the original
crash bandicoot trilogy gives it a nice
polish and it's ready to play again it
looks amazing
not that the ps1 games so it's still
look really good like there's something
very lovely about that old ps1 look yeah
it still looks great today yeah I hope I
hope with insane jollies I think you're
right I think the ps1 games it for crash
and Spyro still look good today because
at the end of the day they had good art
styles but yeah I really hope that the
insane trilogy and the reignited trilogy
helped bring these two amazing series to
an entire new fan base you know because
there are people far younger than us
that a problem we're playing these games
for the first time and hopefully to them
it's still as good as what it is in our
own minds but yeah I think even though
I've you know I've poked fun at you and
it crash today I do really enjoy a crash
bandicoot and and although I do prefer
Spyro I think the both series are
incredible and I can't wait to play more
of them hopefully we'll get some actual
new games as well as these remastered
stats a very fair ugly there you have
anything to say again see of them we
going to play crash on the switch so
portable now baby shut up let's go well
that ended on a more even note than
usual but let us know who you think
debated their case better by voting in
our poll in the top right corner of the
video or if you're over on Gamescom by
putting your thoughts in the comment
section down below
it'll be your votes that decides who
wins so make yourselves heard right time
for this week's quickfire round a series
of dumb fun questions written by the
rest of the UK team naturally Oscar will
have no idea what's coming their way
if
both crash and Spyro ran for the US
presidency who do you think would win as
far as very eloquent I'm sure he's got
some very good views actually on the
economy and you know international
relations and that kind of thing it's
sort of all the world's problems farah
mainly just by burning the bad people
with his flame breath so pretty much
what's happening right now and do your
best impression of your games mascot or
I can easily do mine because there's
that's Nathan Drake in it oh yeah I can
really do good impression of the TNT box
as well go on pitch the film version of
your game
that's a cracking question I think mine
would be the hangover but with Crash
Bandicoot without being crass and that
is just like in Vegas like alright then
Spyro what would you do them I don't
know I mean the easy answer is
essentially How to Train Your Dragon
with starring me and your boy spy roads
this ain't on a ride Spyro I reckon I've
been on him quite well
be like a child riding a donkey do you
think all rule 34 exists for crash or
Spyro if you type Spyro on Google Images
I guarantee the first page is gonna have
some filth yeah I reckon his horn is in
the rule 34 section of the internet it's
going some places in it whereas crash I
reckon he's a never-nude because of
those jorts see where those don't come
off like that views this body yeah he's
never easy
he's never waned out as he cut there
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argue their case
better and if you enjoy this episode of
vs. make sure to hit that subscribe
button as we'll have new episodes of
this show every Wednesday thanks for
watching see ya
[Music]
you